Okay. Hey, what's going on?
It's bill burr and it is time
for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
Yeah.
Um, oh. Why did I start doing
that? What did I start doing?
I got to do it every time now. Right.
You got to give the crowd what they want.
You know what I love too is I love that
people listen to this and I know that
they have roommates, they have boyfriends,
girlfriends at fucking hate this.
And then every fucking Thursday,
you know,
they got to listen to be obnoxiously yell
like that. And I know right now, Ooh,
folk off.
I asked Warren take time right now to
say I'm sorry to those of you in the
background. I know it must be difficult.
And also, you know what? Fuck Que,
I don't need you. Yeah. Walk
away. I don't give a fuck.
Um, anyway. Oh,
oh fucking Billy red velvet
pancakes is in a great fucking mood.
That's how I've been eating lately. I'm
still working out, but I'm gradually,
the pooches come and the pooch, the
pooch, the pooch is coming back.
Hang in over a man under fucking whiz.
Um,
I'm going to do something about say
pushups and then I'm going to skip rope.
So anyways,
I'm going on.
I'm going on the road tomorrow for two
weeks getting ready for the Madison
Square Garden show. And uh,
for the first leg of it,
it's going to be the four horsemen here.
It's going to be me, Bart, Nick Verdesian,
La hit. And uh, we're all
going to the Notre Dame.
I'm a USC game this weekend
is as far as I know.
I think USC, USC got rid
of their, uh, their coach.
Is that what happened? Why do
I, you know, so you know why?
Cause this is all fucking just, I didn't
know I was going to talk about this.
I'm like, why didn't I look it up?
Why didn't I read about it? You know,
why do you run your fucking mouth
without looking up some shit?
USC coach,
let's see what comes up.
Clay Helton USC did a horrible thing
to Steve Sarkisyan because it had no
choice. Oh, this guy was,
was this guy boozing it up?
Maybe I should call them up.
See what he's doing now.
Probably got time to do the tour right.
See if we can hang with them. You'll see.
Did a horrible thing to Steve
Sarkisyan because it had no choice.
The Trojans put their football future
over the health of a person they
supposedly cared about.
This was probably the best case scenario.
Oh, they put their football future
over the sky. Ra receiving it, Dan.
It was not what? You're good at
editing until this gets done. Uh,
God just say what he did.
He entered treatment,
showed up drunk a couple of
times and that's fucking great.
I mean it's sucks cause
he lost a good job.
But when she love to see taper or that,
I mean body,
take a ne gather out.
Where's my whistle?
Oh it is right there.
Sorry.
At first after his fucking bullshit,
you know,
I know there was [inaudible] problems.
Three
me and a quarter. I can't do
this. This is bad. This port best.
So you know what?
He's going to fucking,
you know what do you got
to tell you something for a
fucking drunk. Look at him.
He looks great.
You know,
it must be all that screaming and yelling
and running up and down the sidelines.
I like that he wears the old school,
uh, you know, football coach,
black cleats. Right? But the
white stripe, that's unfortunate.
Oh that's never fun. Right? To make
fun of a drunk that just lost his job.
So he's a drunk and they'd do a face
plant at work, but he still has his job.
Then it's hilarious. Right? What
happened? Why am I bringing this up?
I'm in a great mood.
I didn't get fired for drinking and
this one is scary things and all my,
you know, my job, I can
not get fired for drinking.
I can not get fired
because I'm self employed.
I can be asked to leave wherever I'm at,
but I'm still a comedian at the end of
the day. Right. So I know it works. Why?
Don't know bill, why don't you keep
drinking and figure it out? Um, anyways,
so I'm in a great mood cause I got out
of the tour starts tomorrow, you know,
we're all going to be a, it's weird.
We're starting with the dessert first.
Usually we do the whole tour
and then we do go to the game.
But how it worked out is the
game comes first. So, uh,
we're all gonna show up, you
know, meet at the hotel bar.
Whoever gets there first will
probably already be there.
I think Versie gets their last,
which means he's going to
become wheeling in his bag.
Probably we'll get one in him
before he even gets to the room.
Come on Paul to a shot, do a shot. Um,
you know, this is going to be awesome.
And then a couple of my buddies
fly in the following day.
We pick them up the airport. We go
straight to the game to the legendary,
uh, confines of whatever the fuck. And
the name was a touchdown Jesus stadium.
I have no idea.
Uh,
but I've wanted to go there for a long
time and I have a weird thing with Notre
Dame where I always wanted
to go there when I was a kid.
Um, it was impossible not to
be a fan, you know what I mean?
They were on TV all the time.
It was the fighting Irish.
I got some Irish blood in me,
although I'm mostly German,
but it was fighting Irish, you know, I
looked like the mascot minus the beard.
Right. So it's just like, you
know, I got into it. So I,
for some reason I wanted to be a lawyer.
Right.
It's probably cause I wanted to be
in front of a crowd. I have no idea.
So when I was in junior high,
I was like,
I wanted to go to Notre Dame and go
to law school and become a lawyer.
That's what I was going to do.
And by the Diet had that dream right up
until the first day of freshman year in
high school.
And by the end of my freshman year,
I was considering going to Wentworth
Institute Boston and getting into
construction.
Um,
I'm not going to get into the details
of it, but let's just say it a,
it went off the rails, went
off the rails quick. You know,
I basically,
if you could somehow Ryan leafs,
NFL football career, if you could
just slide that over to academia.
Is that a word to academics? That's
what happened, you know, and in the end,
you know, halfway through my freshman
year, rather than screaming at a reporter,
you know, I was probably
yelling at my mom, I don't know.
Yeah,
well you have to,
you're not going to go to college.
I love that. And get your grades
up so you can go to college.
It's like go to college.
I can't even handle high school.
Fuck are you talking about, it's like
sucking at the college level. Hey,
try a little harder so you can get
to the NFL doesn't work that way.
It does with academics, right. You
can get way in over your fucking head.
Next thing you know,
you're in a major,
you don't even want to be
in and all of that shit.
You gotta get the fuck out of it.
Right. So anyways, I absolutely,
whose kid knew I had completely just,
I fucking tanked.
I tanked.
You know,
like when they say like the coach lost
the locker room and he can tell the
team's just not out there
trying, you know, that was me.
I lost my whole drive somewhere
during my junior year.
I was just like, you know, what am I
going to summer school again this year?
I might as well just have a good time.
I remember in math class I used to get
like my test back and I get like a seven.
It was always a funny number B. What'd
you get? I guess 75 I got on that bill.
What'd you get? I'd be like, I've
got a nine. I remember getting a 17.
I got an 11.
Like everything I got on the test,
like we're like quarterback
numbered jerseys.
I got a Burt Jones,
I got a Troy Aikman.
I got to Steve Grogan and uh,
who's 17 dandy don Meredith
was the 1717 is a tough one.
Um, I got a Roflik Burger,
uh, which is also Burt Jones.
That's number seven Raymond bore right
back then my freshman year of high school,
that was still a Raymond Bork until
my sophomore year, somewhere around.
Then he changed to number 77 and speaking
of the Bruins, hey, we go, bro Ain't,
here we go. Um, I fucking love this tape.
All right. It sucks that because his
salary cap and whatever other reasons,
they had to get rid of Hamilton,
Lou Cheech and all these guys.
Tyler's saying all of these
fucking guys over the years. Um,
I'm literally watching my own team and I
have like the Bruins Nhl site opened up
onto the raw stuff so I
can figure out who's who,
and I'm not going to lie to you, you know.
Oh, we had some rough ones, you know, um,
Winnipeg,
we got pounded.
MMM.
I should, we did okay
for the first, you know,
half of the game and then
it just went off the rails.
Same thing happened with the Canadians.
And then we jumped out to a two to
nothing lead against Tampa Bay and,
uh,
and ran at the end of the period,
we let up two quick ones and um,
you know, and then the rest of the
shit happened. And then, I dunno what,
so anyways, last night we finally,
we played the fucking, uh,
the avalanche and we fucking
jumped on them early.
We stayed on him and we got
to, that 10 minute period
is, uh, in the second period.
That was just like, no, all right, all
right, please don't fucking implode.
And we got all the way right to the end
and then we took it fucking double mine
and a, the score to fucking goal.
I think at that point it was like,
it's either three to nothing of four
to nothing. Then it became four to one,
then it was five, nothing, some five
to two. And I thought, you know,
in the third period I thought we
were gonna fuck it up, but we didn't,
we hung in there. We got our first, uh,
we got our first victory and your illness,
Gustafson Gustafson was in net and a,
I just want to say to Provence, France,
don't jump all over. Tuka I know
he led in a ton of fucking goals,
but also we had a bunch of
new guys and um, you know,
don't do that Boston thing,
that New York thing,
that east coast fucking thing where
you're only as good as your last fucking
game where you know,
you know,
forget the fact of all the
successes that these guys had.
Same thing with the head
coach and everything. So, um,
because there's so many new players,
what they did before the Bruins game is
what I wish they would do before every
hockey game. If anybody connected,
working with the NHL is listening.
If you want to get people
a little more on board,
every other fucking sport does this
before the fucking game starts.
Like if you're watching a baseball
game, they'll just be showing the, the,
the whole baseball fields and then they'll
just put the names of all the players
of where they're at and they'll do it.
Football teams.
And then they showed the lineups.
You know, they give you a chance,
they do it in football or fences on,
they show the offense and they
show the other team's defense.
And then the other people get the ball
the same fucking thing for some reason in
hockey
where it's going 90 fucking zillion
miles an hour and you have substitutions
happening while the puck is still in play.
For some reason they never fucking do it.
So before the Bruins game,
they did it and this was what
our lines look like. They had,
our first line was Ericson,
Bert Bergeron,
Ron and Conley than we had.
I didn't even know how to say
Boleski crazy pasta knock.
And then Kelly Hayes,
ah,
you had fucking four points last night.
Then it was Rinaldo Kim pining and
Talbot was our fourth line. So then,
you know, I started looking up the
numbers and I'm able to get on. I'm, I'm,
I'm all caught up.
I still haven't watched the Winnipeg game.
I'm watching that today, so
I'll be all caught up and, uh,
hopefully heard Brad Marshawn and starting
to skate with the team again. So I'm,
I'm fucking site. And I think
that play playing well, you know,
we just had to learn to kind of a,
I dunno,
we weren't getting physical with anybody.
We're just sort of skating
the fuck around and, uh,
we'd let up a couple of goals and then we,
I don't know,
it took a bunch of penalties. I got
to tell you though, our power play,
it looks like shit though. Our
power play looks like shit, but uh,
we're great at killing penalties. God
knows, you know, if you take 90 a game,
you get pretty good at it.
You get a lot of practice.
I think we took like seven or eight
when we played the Canadians, but, um,
but anyways, I'm, I'm,
I'm on board, you know,
I thought this was going
to be a brutal year.
Like is it for the last few games
is as bad as they're going to play.
I'm watching every fucking game.
I can totally handle it and it's going to
be interesting to see what they can do.
A, if we can maybe add,
we don't really have,
we don't have a guide who's going to
score like 40 goals. I don't feel, I mean,
maybe we could if they start to gel,
but we just don't have anything
like that on our team. And, uh,
but I was like, and we would take in
a little bit more less shit. You know,
our defensemen McQuaids always good
to fucking clear somebody else.
So it's Chara obviously, but uh, we'll see
how the rest of this goes down. But uh,
I'm fucking psyched. I'm psyched. But I'm
going on the Rodeo for like two weeks,
so I got to figure out how to use that.
Um,
that shit where you can
watch the game. Oh, you know,
I'm going with Bochnik barnacles.
Show me how to do it.
You don't have to feel like right now
I'm not even doing a podcast anymore.
I'm just sort of talking to
myself as unpacking. I apologize.
Let's get back to the podcast here.
So whatever we got our first two points,
we're not in the cellar anymore and
I'm actually debating getting the NBA
package this year to step might
start watching the Celtics to, um,
you know,
my marriage will suffer if I get both.
If I get both of those going and
the NFL, you know, fucking happy,
I'm going to be upset. My wife's
going to be, this is how cool Nina is.
You know what?
She got me the other day,
she got me this thing that
makes round ice cubes,
these giant round ice cubes that you
stick in your drink for when you're having
a little lick.
And she only got me one because she
wasn't sure if it was going to fucking uh,
if it was going to, if I was going
to like it. And I absolutely love it.
So I've been making them all day.
You know what the fucking movie was?
It was it good fellas when they
will make them like the eight balls,
that's what I'm doing
except with ice cubes.
And my goal is to have it all filled
up these round ice cubes, you know?
Oh Shit.
I just came up with a brutal idea.
What you could do with
those kids do not do this.
I figure everybody listens to this is
too old for a snowball fight member.
Back in the day when you fucking hated
somebody who made the old ice ball,
everybody's throwing snow and then you'd
fucking put some ice in the middle of
it. You always took that one either
to the fucking side of the head,
took it right to the temple or you took
it in the knee cap one or the other.
I always caught you right on a fucking
phone. It was never, you know what I mean?
You've got this giant
fucking winter coat on.
You're wearing basically a flak jacket.
It would never hit that.
Come sail and right in and he
got you stupid knitted cap. What?
The palm palm on it. By the way, could the
NFL make those hats any fucking bigger?
How dumbed did Tom Brady and uh,
what's is there Cameron Crowe there
that plays for the fucking, uh,
the fucking panthers look dead.
Giant stupid hat on both of them.
Tom,
Tom Brady and uh, Nate Newton.
What the fuck is his name? Walk.
God dammit. What's the fuck's the name
of the guy he played from off for Auburn?
He won the Heisman trophy.
They said he was cheating.
Is it Cameron? I fucking
don't know. Anyways,
both Tim and Tom Brady,
they have like movie
star good looks right.
The two of them be put those fucking ads
on him and I kick [inaudible] wearing
like they're adults. Oh,
hang on a sec. Hello.
Hey, um, I'm doing the podcast. They
got you on speaker. Say what's up. Oh,
hi. Hi. I'll see you in a minute.
But um,
anyways,
why don't we make the hats so
fucking big is my big question.
I want to speak in the NFL football.
If I could just dance all over the fucking
place here because I'm so excited to
go on the road. My add is just flying
off the fucking rails here. Um,
to the point,
just cause I said that,
I just forgot what the fuck I was
going to talk about. Nfl Football,
the Patriots are playing the crying cults,
the Indianapolis Crying Colts.
They're playing him this weekend.
Andrew luck chart though. So we'll see.
We'll see. What the fuck happens. I will,
you know, if we beat them or whatever,
I don't want, I'm not gonna
fucking talk any shit because a,
I'm not going to be like,
um,
because I know luck isn't 100%. So
that's the thing too about the patriots.
It's like we got this gaudy record, but
I don't feel like we've played anybody.
You know, the Steelers weren't the
Steelers, right? We played Jacksonville,
they stank, we played the bills. You know,
they're still trying to find their way.
And then we played the
cowboys without Tony Romo.
So here we are sitting on four now, you
know, I don't know. I'd like to see, uh,
how we do against the packers is something
that giants are starting to come on.
SLAAC and Eli Manic. Ah, my God,
if we never see Eli manning
again in the playoffs, you know,
happy. I will be. I totally,
I'm telling you the
football gods love that man.
I got this big debate with Paul
and I was going through it.
He's basically drew breeze with the
defense. He's not as good as Brady.
He's not as good as Peyton
manning. He's, he's got dude,
he's fucking gangster and all this shit.
And what it really was is I know the
guys, the shit, what it was was when,
the way that the giants beat
the 40 niners was it last week?
I've been running around so much.
The way that they beat them made me
have a flashback to when they beat us.
When we were undefeated,
it was the same fucking thing.
I watched Eli throw a pic to
lose the game and I watch it.
I watched it get dropped.
And you do not want to
give that second chance.
Who's getting hope you like?
It's a lot of the fucking credit,
but it was their front format and then
front for stray in and all those guys
kicked the shit out of
our old line briefly.
The game fucking running for his life.
I mean that was,
that had a lot to do with it.
But uh,
Eli also made this fucking huge place
that I don't want to see that guy again.
I just, you know, it's funny as far as
he's going like, dude, he, you know,
even the New York media, they keep jumping
on the guy that always jumping on him,
you know,
he's like,
look at Brett Farve Brett or five
two with a bunch of interceptions.
You'd help blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah, all this
shit, you know? And he goes,
they just liked him because he
was a hick and I was like, dude,
Eli and Brett Farve of, I'm not mistaken.
And from the same state, aren't they?
Both from Louisiana.
This is the deal.
The problem Eli has is mechanically,
he's not as good as his brother, even
though I would take him in the playoffs,
um, over his brother, I think
for whatever fucking reason.
And he's just had more success.
And that the reason why I
think people jump on Eli,
the man just does not look
good in a football uniform.
He doesn't look good. When he
puts his, puts the helmet on,
he just doesn't look good,
you know?
And then when he's ease out
in his street clothes, yeah,
he's walking around wearing like action
slacks and a fucking sweater, you know,
partners here on the side.
Like he's still in the third grade.
It's like he's asking for it.
I don't want to blame the victim,
but the man is fucking asking for it.
However,
I do think he's the shit and if somehow
it works out that the giants get
healthy, you know, Jpp you know,
comes back, right. And they somehow,
you know,
have a better record or they go in and
they'd beat Green Bay in Green Bay and we
faced them in the Superbowl. I'm telling
you right now, I am not watching it.
I'm not sitting through that again. And I
know what you're thinking. Jesus Christ.
Bill, I think you're a fan and your
team. I am. I am a fan of my team.
But how many times can you get fucking
slap to the face before you don't start
Winston first? You know, um,
although it would be great to come
back and try to avenge those to God we
fucking gave it. Didn't give it to
them. We gave them two up to something.
Samuel dropped that pick Brady
to Welker three yard pass.
Those fuckups allowed
Eli to become a legend.
All right. Now I'm not
taking it away from me. Like,
cause he'd had the fucking
deliver any did. Um,
oh my God,
it makes me sick to my stomach thinking
we're going to play the fucking giants
again. Jesus Christ. You
think winning four of them,
you could just fucking
walk it off and be happy.
But now I'm actually gonna try to do a
podcast with Rappaport right after. Uh,
we play each other and nobody
talks shit like that guy.
If you guys listened to him on stern
when he does the fantasy football thing,
Rapaport is out of his fucking mind.
Um,
so giant fence.
If you guys win,
you're going to want to tune in to his
podcast. If I'm on their Patriot fans,
you get a maybe want to take
up a cyclic or something.
You might want to skip that
one. Um, anyway, so let me
do some, uh, let me do laugh.
Fuck, I forgot to bring this shit up.
I forgot to bring it. You know what?
I forgot to bring it down.
I bring up the draft kings thing.
I love talking about
these guys cause I love,
I love that people thought that
they were going to fucking somehow,
you know what I had real,
do you realize that sports stadiums
have like draft king little fucking like
booths there
or thinks they are at least three?
Is it just they're advertised. There's no
way they have the boots at the stadium.
I have to look that up because if they do,
they're literally the sports book.
Let me look this up. Draft
King. Needless to say,
they're never going to fucking advertise
on this thing anyways and I can't help
it. I can't not talk about this.
This is fucking fascinating. Alright.
Draft kings booths at stadiums
probably boost isn't the right thing.
VIP experience. She lets stay
premium seating. Nah that's not it.
Maybe they just say I I saw somebody
showed where they had like one of those,
what do you call it?
An awning and it said draft kings on.
It's like there's no way you can walk up.
That'll probably be be like the next
thing. But whatever that I told you.
I think I told the story
the last time about the, uh,
that thing on fan duel where the guy
worked on Wall Street and said, you know,
I'm quitting my Wall Street job to
try to win $1 million on fan duel.
And then of course he does. Of course he
does, right? Because that's all you do.
Just, you know, pick your players and the
pickup your cash. Simple as that. Right?
So the guy wins and fucking
Billy does and then quit.
I'm to believe that this man walks
away from a six figure job to take his
million dollar earnings that are now
about four and 80 grand after taxes,
and he's now going to take that in,
invested as new business of gambling on
football and that he's not going to end
up being homeless. Um, anyways,
I feel at this point I'm just fucking
beaten a dead, a beating a dead horse.
I always hated that fucking scene.
Beating a dead horse. It's like, oh,
it was okay to beat it when
it's alive. You can't, you know
it back in the day when I,
when me and uh,
first you were talking about
what you would do if you, uh,
had like a time machine. I think I just
figured out what the fuck I would do.
I would go back in time and I would
fucking abuse people. Abusing animals.
Okay.
Well then again, if I was
going to do that, then what
about human being expelled?
You're gonna go in there and
try and stop slavery. Yeah.
Go back and try to give the fucking
native Americans a little heads up.
What the fuck am I read for this week?
Youtube video.
What happened to Canada?
Hollywood improv.
You dispute has been escalated to a claim.
What the fuck is that?
Yeah.
Disconnect. Where the fuck is
the fucking Jesus Christ? Oh,
I'm in the wrong one here.
I'm in the wrong account.
Okay.
Why do I have so many accounts? All right.
Here we go. Sorry. Jesus. Chris, you guys,
just walk it off. Go make yourself
a sandwich and a couple of seconds.
I'll get back to the podcast here.
Come on, come on. Come on. Ah,
there's the re there's
the reeds. All right. Uh,
club w club, Debbie. Um,
don't you hate when wine looks like a 10,
but it winds up tasting like a six or
even worse when you walk into the store to
pick out your wine. You could easily be
fooled into a situation just like this.
Well now I'll just like this meeting,
the thing before I thought
you were set me up for yeah,
I'd like judge wine by the label
and I refuse to buy any wine that's,
that has the name of somebody. I'm
not buying Paul Newman's fucking, uh,
Sierra mist, whatever the fuck you
call a wine. You know his Barolo.
I'm not doing that. It's like, dude,
I'll buy your fucking dressing.
I'll buy your popcorn. I know
it goes to a good cause. Okay.
I'm trying to get fucked up here.
All right.
It has to be somebody famous that's
like notoriously a fucking drunk.
Like if the guy from USC, if the
coach, if he put out a wine right now,
although wine I was, man, they'll
drink fucking $2 bottles. So fuck that.
That's a bad thing. I Dunno.
Anyways. Well now here.
Well now there's this new wine club
club Debbie Club dubby for we watch.
Shame on you fool me. Get, you're
not gonna fool me again. This.
They've changed everything.
No more being fooled by wines that
pretend to be harder or tastier than they
actually are. It's
easy. Just go to club w.
Dot com and answer six simple questions.
Their algorithm creates a
power profile just for you.
I don't feel like they're
explaining this right.
There's like a zillion
different kinds of wines.
How the hell do you know
what's good? What's bad? Yeah.
I basically, I personally,
I judge it on how much it costs
or how cool the label looks.
You know what I mean? That's no
way to do it. These guys will say,
what do you like in your wine?
They come up with a formula, right?
Just take out your cash and
they'll pick out the wine.
This is the draft kings of fucking,
I'll fucking wine.
Oh, okay. So they come up
with the algorithm and a
Palette profile, just view.
Then they dig.
Just send why directly to your door?
Perfectly customized to match your tastes.
Club w tear is the leading is leading
the grape to glass wine revolution.
They worked directly with the
vignettes to cut out the middle man,
which saves you a lot of Moolah.
So with club Debbie,
you get freemium wine,
customize to your tastes at a third
of what you'd pay at the store.
Forget about all the bottles you
buy that you actually think stink.
They even have a no risk hundred percent
guarantee that you'll love what they
send you.
And Right now club Debbie Club Darby.
I'm a war president.
Club Dubey is offering my listeners 50%
off your first order when you go to club
debbie.com/tara Oli Amigos Club Debbie.
So stop wasting your time and money
messing around at the retail stores and
start drinking wine. You know you're going
to love. Just go to club Debbie Dotcom.
Daddy,
I've learned how to speak Spanish.
Loved Debbie Dotcom Slash Berg
to get 50% off your first order.
That's club debbie.com/burr
okay.
That's just as hard.
You know,
I wanted to try a different beer and
there's like a zillion of them. I just,
I can't get into these things
like, you know, ugly dog.
Go Fuck yourself all.
Always have these cool names and
then you drink them and they stink.
You know what I mean? All of that fucking,
you know, angry vineyard, you know,
fuck you orchard, all of
that stuff. Crazy mix,
donkey punch, you know, ball
bag, brew, all of that stuff.
The hoppy, you know, Honduras,
whatever the fuck it is.
None of it's, you know, you know what
I bought that absolutely fucking sucks.
I bought Guinness Blonde Ale.
I'm telling you right now,
if you ever just wanted to buy a six pack,
have a sip and then dump the rest in
a sewer. That is the beer for you.
I Love Guinness,
but Jesus Christ.
Okay,
that's a classic. Stick to what you
know they have Freddie. All right.
Identify the pain of
hiring. Oh, zip recruiter.
All right.
As a business owner,
your company is only as good as the people
you hire. Posting jobs at one place.
It's not enough to find quality
candidates. Short staff,
short staffing leaves little time to post
to dozens of job sites. Jesus Christ.
What do you do while you can position
zip recruiter is the solution or am I
supposed to do that?
Okay,
I don't understand this copy.
Just send me the copy and
stop telling me what to do.
But to position Ziprecruiter is a
solution. Don't know what to do.
Go to Ziprecruiter,
everybody.
You can post to 100 plus job
sites with one single click.
Be instantly matched to candidates
from over 6 million resumes. Uh,
plus watch brand new candidates
roll into ZipRecruiter's.
Easy to use interface within 24 hours.
Ziprecruiter has been used
by over 400,000 businesses.
Insert approve user testimonial.
I think this is more like a professional
chef. All right, I'll do one. I had a job,
oh, selling low. I had to take a,
and then nobody was selling lemonade
and this guy came up and afford ranch.
He slowed down and he kept
going and I was thinking, shoot,
that could've got me 35 cents.
I need someone else to help me.
So then I went to zip recruiter
and I said, hey, you watch
work, a lemonade stand.
Next thing you know,
over 40 are the most authentic
individuals I've ever seen in my life.
Who actually thought that over
the age of 35 working at 11 age,
Dan was a good deal.
They got to me.
Can I was able to hire nine of
them and that never happened again.
I piss and shit whenever I want.
Thank you. Zip Recruiter. All right.
Call to action today.
You can go to [inaudible].
You can try zip recruiter for free.
Go to ziprecruiter.com/bird that's dip,
ziprecruiter.com/bar one more time.
ziprecruiter.com/burp. All
right, let's get back to the,
uh, the podcast here. What do
we got left? Oh my God, dude,
I'm so fucking excited to go to that
Notre Dame game. Oh, the drinking.
We're gone and drank a bunch of
beers. Smoke in this. Say Guys,
be in a Douche. Rudina oh no,
I'm going to root for the end.
I'm going to root for the Irish.
You know I'm going to root for the Irish
over fucking USC. I never liked USC.
You know, if they just had one more
fucking song that the band could play,
I literally think I could make
the USC band playing trumpet.
If it can be fucking six weeks,
I could learn how to golf
58 fucking times a quarter.
I'm not the most creative people. They're
down at USC. You know what I mean?
I don't get it. They got the
money, you know. Um, all right.
Uh, okay. We got to wrap this
thing up cause I've got a
bunch of shit I got to do,
so I'm actually going to be on the road
and uh, um, when I'm done doing this shit,
did I mention I'm going to be on the road?
Uh,
I'm actually running down to the grocery
store and I'm gonna make some pumpkin
bread cause every year I make it
from my fucking name, you know,
and I don't get back until November,
beginning of November.
So I'll miss um,
Miss Halloween.
So I'm going to knock out
a couple of loaves here.
Make like four or five tonight with my
round ice cube. Fucking whiskey going out.
It's going to be the shit.
It's going to be the shit I might,
I haven't smoked a cigar. Well over
two weeks. I am so ready to fucking go.
Um, I swear to God. I'm ready.
I'm ready to run to the fucking airport.
I'd ladies do you get this
fucking exciting? What, what
gets you going like this?
There's gotta be something.
I know it is.
There's no way you go to life
not getting this excited.
I'm meeting five of my favorite
guy friends in the fucking,
like I have women friends.
I don't have any women friends.
Five of my favorite friends
in the fucking world to booze,
smoked cigars and go to
the Notre Dame USC game.
I like one of my buddies is
going to be on my fucking flight.
It is going to be a
wire to wire shit y'all.
I can't wait. Oh, we're going to be bleary
by the time we get to Fort Wayne. Um,
I'm really looking forward
to Fort Wayne to, and um,
I understand some of you guys,
if you can't fucking make it cause the
patriots are playing the cults, um,
at that time I get it. What are you
going to do? That totally makes sense.
So anybody who's shown up to that,
thank God, bless you. God bless you.
You know what I mean?
I might even go out and take some
fucking pictures with the afterwards.
I should fucking do that. You know,
I should do that in Fort Wayne.
You know what I mean? Go out there
amongst all your drunk, you know,
she'd come up to me, hammered,
spitting in my face, not meaning to,
and then I got to wipe it off. I'll
don't, I'm sorry. Did I get ya? You know,
um, I might even go out there.
I might even go out there.
Usually what I do is I go
right back to the fuck.
And the same thing you would do.
You're done with your job.
Are you going to go hang around for more
job or are you going to go out to your
car and start drinking?
That's what the fuck I would do.
It's a no brainer. Um, all right.
I'm sorry. I'm being a criteria.
They'll bill you really going to grace
us with your big fucking head. You can't.
What makes you think we're not
going to drive away? You're
arrogant. Fuck, I dunno.
Um, anyways, let's, let's wrap
this up here. Uh, before I go.
Uh, Lamar Odom, everybody, man,
I hope this for some reason
he pulls through and uh,
thank God he's actually at this point
surrounded by Kardashians in that film
crew to uh,
let him know that they really care so
they can get all the crying on camera so
they can fucking get some ratings.
Jesus Christ. That bet I heard that day.
That's what they're doing.
That better not be true.
That poor guy seems like the
nicest fucking guy ever. Um,
because I'm sitting in glorifying, going
out boozing and shit. Jesus Christ.
I hope the guy pulls through
obviously. Um, so that is it.
The, how can I end on that note
then? I guess it was a negative,
but it's sad. I'll tell you what one. Um,
okay.
All right. That's how happy story.
This morning I had flown, you know,
doesn't the helicopter
thing and well over a month.
So I had to get down there just because
I knew I was going to be gone for
another two weeks. I didn't
want to get too rusty. Um,
so I did a flight this morning and
it was just like no one was up there.
It was so fucking clear. It was one of
the sickest flights I've ever done. I,
um, transition, uh,
through lax is airspace
like 150 feet off the water,
flew right over these guys
sitting on surfboards.
I was so low I could actually look.
And I saw a father telling his son to
look up at the helicopters, were going by,
made a right turn at Santa Monica.
Piers flew right over a write up Santa
Monica right by the use you as a UCLA
campus. And then I went over to the Fox
slot where I just had some acting work,
flew right over where we
were shooting. And then, um,
I flew back over to where my houses
did a lap around the top of my house.
And then went over to the rose bowl,
did a lap around that,
um, data, low approach
at El Monte airport,
straight out departure and then landed
back at fucking long beach was it was the
shit.
I'm so happy I did that because it was
getting to the point is that thing where
you don't do it for a while and you
stay stuck getting nervous again. Like,
Oh fuck Darren, remember how to
do this shit? So I'm one of the,
I dunno, maybe this is only
appealing to people that uh,
that have a pilot's license,
but I got to tell you like the,
the fucking privilege to be able to do
that and the feeling you get when you're
up there is really a indescribable,
um,
such a cool thing.
But I'm still,
I get nervous like about making the
call when you got to go through Bravo
airspace because you got
to have total fucking 100%.
They got to read you a whole tail number
is one of these things where they can
say you have clearance but they don't
read your hotel number and you got to say
back to them your whole fucking tail
number or else your in trouble even though
they fucked up. You know what I
mean? I don't want to get in trouble.
That's like the, that's what I
had the biggest nightmare of.
I don't even have anything about the
engine cutting out anymore. You know,
I've done enough of those auto rotations.
We did a few more today.
We only did one, but I, you know, I did
a great job, you know, stimulating, um,
engine failure. Granted, you
know, if I got a nice long
fucking runway to pick out,
you know, it was funny when we were
flying today, they were doing the uh,
the earthquake,
um,
drill at all of the schools.
So every school I f I flew over or flu
near had a bunch of kids standing out in
the field, which was unsettling because
those are the places I, you know,
you look and like if I have a problem,
that's where the fuck I'm landing.
And you look down, there's a bunch of
kids there and you're like, all right,
now I've got to try to put it
down on the street. You know,
there's all these wires and the fucking
traffic lights and all that shit. But, um,
it was an unbelievably clear day.
Um,
and it was also cool out. It
wasn't hot fluid, the doors off.
It was the fucking shit. Um, it
was awesome. So anyways, I didn't,
what the fuck I'm babbling about here?
Uh,
and I'm sure I was all over the map and
I was probably talking too fast here,
but I'm excited to do this tour and
to do the run through the Midwest.
Once again. We're going to be doing Fort
Wayne. We do in Cincinnati, Columbus,
Cleveland, Pittsburgh,
Milwaukee, Chicago, Minneapolis.
I might've forgot one in there, but
uh, with Taryn all the way through the,
the Midwest and um,
we got law ahead with us right through
Columbus. He's not doing Pittsburgh,
but he's doing, um, he is
going to do Cleveland and uh,
the after party, by the way,
the afterparty and Cleveland,
if you guys want to hang out with us is
going to be at hilarity. His comedy club.
Um, they got the Martini bar. We're
going to be going there after the show.
Uh, nick cost is one of my
favorite people in this business,
the owner of hilarity.
And he used to headline me there when
I would draw like 30 or 40 people.
So whenever I come to town
I always make sure that, um,
I always make sure that I, I stopped
by say hello and thank you to him.
Whenever I go to Pittsburgh,
I always make sure I say,
what's up and thank you to Randy Bauman,
a Wd v e uh,
built me up in that market,
you know, big time hockey fan
and all that type of shit.
He always breaks my balls
about the fucking Patriot
being cheaters and all that
shit. So a lot of good stuff to be looking
forward to coming up. And once again,
thanks to everybody who's bought
tickets and that's it for the Thursday
afternoon, Monday morning
podcast just before Thursday.
Throwback Shit for you.
I'll see out there on the road.
Yeah.
Nervous Scott.
Um,
uh,
my college,
has been dating his fiance for two years.
He's a really nice guy so he tends
to get walked all over Jesus Christ.
I have to read that again because there's
so much that right there is something
that every guy needs to hear.
He's a really nice guy so he
tends to get walked all over.
I'm not saying you have to be a dick.
All right.
But you got to stick up for
yourself. Okay, here we go.
Even before they got engaged,
I had heard rumors about his girlfriend
being a bit of a hole where as his
friend.
Okay.
As his friend and her pretend friend,
I attempt to give her the benefit of
the doubt and ignore the accusations,
as did my roommate who had also heard
the rumors unless she was drunk and got
out of control and belittling him.
We didn't mind.
We didn't mind her too much aside for her.
Trying too hard to be one of the guys.
Okay. Recently. Okay,
now this one I'm fucking up reading
because he's naming all names. Recently,
uh,
Ebenezer called to me and said that uh,
Tabitha had kissed a guy at a bar.
Okay.
And that the,
okay.
Recently the fucking potential groom
called up to say that the fucking his
fiance who were,
had kissed a guy at a bar and that
they were postponing their wedding and
starting fresh.
I was just surprised to hear
that he wasn't dumping this
bitch. Uh, but whatever.
Not My choice. At least he knew
about it. So after starting fresh,
what seemed to be the fifth time it
appeared that they were working it out.
Of course, this is when
things go completely off the
rails with one phone call,
a friend,
another friend who knew nothing about
the cheating kiss that happened a few
weeks ago tells me that a friend of
his from college was told by his whore
fiance that she would break off the
engagement if he gave her a chance.
Just fucking yesterday.
What?
Well, why can't she just open up
her mouth and break it off anyways?
The source seems reliable,
but it's still just hearsay.
All of his friends now know,
but somehow the potential groom doesn't.
There is no easy way to
bring this up to him. So, um,
up to here, any advice? Thanks
for the podcast and the podcast.
Select hope to see you
perform against soon. Oh fuck.
Okay.
All right. You got to make
a call here. You got a,
you got to decide whether or not you're
prepared to put your friendship on the
table because a,
why don't you want to tell him this shit
basically because you're worried that
he's not going to believe you.
He's gonna flip the fuck out and then
he's going to go ahead and marry this
whore anyways, and the two of
you aren't going to be friends.
Okay?
I gotta tell you this dude,
it's gonna make you sick to your fucking
stomach to watch this guy go through
this shit. Let's say you keep your
mouth shut. You stay friends with them.
Then you kind of sit there and you're
going to watch this girl fuck around on
him.
You know,
I don't know why guys choose to do this.
Women don't.
If women see a dude fucking around, they
go right to that girlfriend. Oh my God,
am I God? He fucking, I thought
blah blah blah, blah, blah.
And they hug and they say, I'm sorry.
I'll be there for you. You can do better.
And they try and fucking for some
reason guys, we can't do that.
I don't know what it is.
I don't know if because it's an ego thing.
He can't handle it. You girls
been fucking around, but a dude,
you got to tell this guy, you got
to tell this guy, fuck this girl.
Don't let another fucking whore go out
there and take some guy for all he's
worth because this bitch is going to get
knocked up and this guy's going to be
into her for 18 fucking years financially.
Okay.
And just like that other guy said, where
is the God damn justice? All right,
what you need sir, is a clear
conscience. You have to say something,
all right. And just tell him,
just tell them. Say, look,
you're going to hate me for
telling you this, but as a friend,
I have to tell you this.
I can't sit back
and hold onto this information.
I got to tell you and I support
whatever decision you want to make.
And all you gotta do is just tell him
the facts without calling his fiance a
whore. Don't say that. Just say
what you know and then that's it.
And tell him, dude, I really
think you need to dump this girl.
You can do way better and that's
it. And he gets fucking mad at
Ya. He gets mad at you and if he cuts
you out, he cuts you out. But this,
but you will not have,
you won't have a guilty conscious.
It won't be weighing on you. I'm
telling you, and I don't know,
some other people say,
you know,
mind your own fucking business when
it comes to this stuff. I don't,
you get in there and tell them shifts.
If one of your buddies is going to
marry a whore, you got to tell him.
You got to tell him.
I saw that happen to a guy. I know.
I saw it, saw it fucking happened.
It was fucking disco. It was
horrible. It was horrible.
And I was younger and I
didn't fucking say anything.
And then the whole fucking thing
unraveled. About 15 years later,
it was just awful. Fucking wasted. A
decade to half of his goddamn life.
Um, looking back should have said
something but did not, did not.
So I'm telling you to do what I didn't do.
I can't judge it because I didn't do it.
[inaudible]
I brought a video camera with me this
weekend. I forgot my little tripod stand.
Um, oh, I forgot to tell you. So
this, this fucking audience member,
it's audience man. You know what,
you know, you don't want to know why,
how I just remembered the audience member.
If you want to get an idea
of how my brain works,
I just realized that I forgot when
I said tripod. I was, you know,
those little mini tripod things.
I was picturing setting up my video
camera and then I immediately imagined
fucking somebody in my room.
And then I thought about this
girl this weekend who came by,
who had the most phenomenal titties
I've seen on the road and a long time.
Yup.
And then that took me to being in the
bar and this what this Douche said.
All right,
so I'm hanging at the Bar,
right? I'm drinking a a what
the fuck was I drinking?
I was drinking cranberry and soda.
All right.
The girl with the phenomenal tits is
showing how she can do that fucking Hulk
Hogan thing. So everybody's watching.
It's phenomenal. And then this guy goes,
hey bill, they'll come. I,
well I deep rich second cause
I'm like, all right. Yeah.
Why don't I talk to you instead of
watching this girl fucking Mover d cup
titties as I drink cranberry juice.
Do you understand sir?
I'm not drinking anymore. You
know, I don't fuck around.
So this is my own little innocent
thing that I can do to make it somewhat
exciting to be here in
Columbus at the mall
anyways.
Some fucking, so I walk over
to this guy. You know what?
Because I'm a nice guy
because I'm generous. No,
because I have a need to be liked.
So I walk over and I'd say,
I started talking to this guy and he
starts asking me 9 million fucking
questions.
Okay
about doing stand up. Like come
on. I even said at one point like,
do what does this inside the
actor's studio? And he goes, no,
I just want to do some good.
And I finally just said, dude,
are you thinking about doing
stand up? And he said, yes.
He's sitting there with his
wife. So I say to the guy, I go,
just write five minutes of
Shit you think is funny.
Go on stage when they call your name. All
right, you'll figure it out from there.
There's no way.
There's nothing more I can do.
It's not like,
I dunno,
teaching somebody how to change the oil.
It's like just something you have to just
jump in the deep end and just hope you
don't drown.
It's just this,
it's the most fucked.
It's the most fucked up thing
ever to try and learn how to do.
Like if you learn how to play guitar,
you can take guitar lessons and you can
get to a certain level of skill before
you actually try to take it out at a
party and play in front of other people.
But stand up you, you have
to, the first time you do it,
you have to do it on a stage while people
watch you. It's fucking, it's unreal.
So that's what I'm trying
to explain to this guy.
He's sitting there with his wife,
he's telling me that he's a banker and
he actually said that a lot of shit that
I say is right on is hitting
the nail right on the head.
So I'm sitting there talking to this
guy and all of a sudden these two other
ladies come over,
all right.
That was part of that
other crew of people.
The girl with the fucking Teddy's that
she was making moves. She goes, hey,
we'll leave at bill. Thanks for the
show. I said, hey, thanks for coming out.
See you next time we come here.
And then he says, hey bill,
how long you've been with your girlfriend?
Just out of the blue. I just went,
I don't know, five, six
years. And then they just,
it got all uncomfortable and
then they left and I'm thinking,
why the fuck did he asked me that,
right. And then then he says to me,
he goes, oh sorry about
bringing up your girlfriend.
I just wanted those girls to leave
cause I wanted to keep talking to you.
And his wife just looks down
at the table like Jesus Christ.
And for some reason in my head I was like,
I was like,
did he think I was fucking
hitting on those girls? Why?
Why the fuck would he do that?
And then I just realized it wasn't until
later I just realized what a fucking
manipulative dirt bag fucking
move that that guy was doing.
And then I was thinking,
thank God he's thinking about doing
stand up because the fact that he's the
banker and he's going to
handle other people's money.
I don't know if he's an investment guy.
I don't know what,
but that's like the kind of guy that will
make old people lead alto and not even
give shit. You know, watch,
he'll become a comedian will probably
end up stealing jokes. Uh, God damn it.
I wish I could just teleport myself back
to that moment in time and just tell
him what an absolute fucking
piece of shit move that was.
Okay.
You know, barest them in
front of his fucking wife and
then left. Just a fucking,
oh,
it was so fucking slimy.
Yeah. Effective. It didn't fucking work.
Second Child.
All right, dear bill. I
am from Kansas City to,
and there's currently radio commercials
and which a law officer, a law,
a law office offers their services
exclusively for women going through a
divorce. Of course they do. There's
a ton of money involved there. Uh,
they talk about how they were view all
of the husband's finances and ensure the
woman will receive the maximum
amount the law will allow.
And then he writes in capital letters.
What the fuck are there any law offices
that offer services exclusively for men?
I doubted if there were,
I would imagine there would be a huge
protest from feminists all across the U S
I know you've addressed
this hundreds of times over,
but why is it okay Kay to completely fuck
a man over this commercial insinuates
the man is already in the wrong.
This is absolute bullshit, dude.
You preach on skies is speaking
the Gospel here. Anyways,
wanted to share this with you as,
this is just another example of man
bashing commercials that just piss me off.
Um, all right, let's, let's,
let's review this. Ah, yeah. Okay.
First of all,
he can't get mad at the lawyers because a,
they're just going with
the is and, um, and as you,
as you, as you say that, if,
if it was the opposite way that there
would be feminist groups protesting.
All right.
That there in lies the fucking problem
until men actually get together and start
protesting that type of shit,
which I would absolutely love to
be a part of on any fucking level.
I would love to see that happen.
But what guys?
We don't do that shit once we get you
get punched in the face. Yeah. Fuck you.
You get up and you walk away. Like
you can't do that. Like, yeah,
this should be guys protesting it. I
think that would be fucking hilarious. Um,
that's absolutely terrifying.
That's one of 9 million reasons
why I never got fucking married.
That is just unfucking believable.
You know,
I'll tell you what kills me is,
uh, most women who would watch it,
they always say the same thing where
you liked, you'll say to them like,
can you believe that shit when they
always say that saint? Yeah, that's right.
That's right. Yeah. That's what
you get. That's what you get. Ah,
big stupid face. What the fuck? Have
you ever done that? That's my whole,
my whole thing with dad.
It's just a, I dunno,
you get married, you just bet a
pray to God. It fucking works out.
There's a guy that's all you have
and the amount of power, it's not,
it's not a balanced relationship because
of the way that the divorce laws are.
It's the second, you know,
it's like when you're single,
you have an unbelievable
amount of power as a guy,
even if you're in a relationship,
because
that she can't get to you legally.
That's it. It's fucking over.
You have your shit and that's it,
and you're a guy and you can earn
a fucking living and that's it.
You don't have to worry about shit.
And then the second you get married,
you lose all power because at any point
should she can just divorce you and
fucking take you for everything. You're
worth, everything you work for. It's,
it's just, it's fucking
over. Look at tiger woods.
Tiger Woods gave his wife a
quarter of a billion dollars.
She was a nanny. Fucking
nanny worth what? Nine figures
for what she, he had a prenup where
she was only going to get $5 million,
only $5 million.
Who here wouldn't kill for $5 million?
I quit my podcast for a fucking 200 grant.
You know,
you find out your husband,
some dog going around
cheating or whatever. That's,
that happens to women.
And the guy's a broke ass son of a
bitch and they're left with nothing.
So it's not like women always make out,
but here's a situation where you
find out you have husbands a dog.
The marriage is over. Oh, but
I get $5 million. But that's
not enough for the cont.
Cause she knows he has a billion and
she wants to get as much as that is.
She can't,
I swear to fucking God,
I can't do these topics because it
makes you see red because they're not
entitled to it. It's bullshit. All right?
If you marry the greatest golfer of a
fucking generation who's won 14 titles,
okay? And you haven't even won a game,
a tiddly winks on a professional level,
you're not entitled to that money. You're
not. You are legally, but you're not.
You didn't fucking earn it. You
can't. Ah, right. There you go. Bill,
get to the core of the hatred.
[inaudible].